Joshua starts us off this hour in Miami
Florida hey Joshua how are you I'm good
Dave I'm a new listener and it's a great
honor to get to talk to you you too sir
how can I help I'm 19 years old you know
I I just got a car not too long ago been
saving up for it probably three months
ago now and long story short I had
gainsco for my auto insurance and I've
decided I'm gonna be moving out to Texas
to live on my own and so I switched to
Allstate now in the process of doing
this you know I went to my old insurance
agency to cancel and as far as I knew
everything was all all good they sent
the paperwork out the gainsco and then
about a week or so later I'm still
getting stuff from gainsco it's it's
actually probably close to a month now
I'm still getting stuff from gainsco I
called gainsco and they said that the
policy is still active that they never
got anything from the agency and now
I've got gainsco coming after me for
debt collection because I never paid in
you know I didn't pay the bill after
after I was supposed to cancel what do
you think I should do should I your
agent your agency should take care of
this right you know yeah I've called
them a bunch of times it's hard to get
hold from any anybody over there and
really it's kind of like a shady place
honestly they're not really helping me
out here okay well I mean you got two
choices you're either going to pay it or
your agency's gonna pay it because
gainsco didn't do anything wrong right
right they weren't notified well since
they weren't notified you owe the money
somebody owes the money right so either
the agency says oh we screwed up and
they talked gainsco into dropping this
so as a favor to them or you're gonna
pay it's probably what a month's worth
of insurance yes $367 yeah you're gonna
pay it if you can't get the agency to to
get them to waive it it's one of those
two
things and let me tell you what not to
do
don't ignore this don't go oh well screw
it I'm not paying it I don't know it I'm
driving off to Texas forget it it'll end
up being $3,000 in collections fees and
lawyers fees and chasing you ten years
from now so put this thing to bed put a
bullet in this thing
stay on it it's worth a lot more than
$360 for you to finish this and so I'm
gonna be doing two things simultaneously
one is I'm gonna make a total nuisance
of myself at this agency you said you
went over there they have a physical
location go over there again sit there I
want to talk to the manager you guys
screwed this up now this company's
chasing me I need you to fix it get on
the phone while I sit here and you fix
it while I'm sitting here and then you
get me something in writing from these
goobers that you it's gone you ride
there but if it takes you an hour it you
made three hundred sixty-seven dollars
an hour if it takes you two hours
you made 150 dollars an hour right right
because otherwise you're gonna end up
paying it or you're gonna you know raise
Cain with gainsco who really didn't do
anything wrong in this story and you
know go guys it was canceled and I need
you guys to call the agency and I need
you guys to waive this it's not my fault
it's not your fault either but I
cancelled it I've been you know did you
have any paperwork the showing you
cancelled it at all well I don't have
anything on my end when I actually went
into the agency you know we had a I had
to sign and date everything yeah did you
even get a copy of that they never
provided me with a buyout and then you
go get you go to the agency get a copy
of that don't leave there without a copy
of it okay because that too will give
you a fight way to fight with gainsco
because the agency represents them not
you that's the problem
and so yeah you just got to make a
nuisance of yourself with both of these
people until this thing goes away or
until you pay it but do not walk off
from it it will follow you my brother
so take care of business here put a bow
on this put a bullet in it finished
business it's over and get everything in
writing and keep a file because you're
dealing with as you said shady people